Sophia are you a muslima what are you
Muslim any
Muslim no muslim
okay Sophia I don't know if you're a
Muslim or not Sophia what are you Sophia
talk to me hello can you hear me you are
a Muslim yes I'm shocked how old are you
Sophia so I don't come off as a bully
I'm 21 okay good you're not young okay
guys I guess my night is just beginning
what's going on Sophia
um so I converted to
Islam about like three years ago sorry
I'm very nervous so yes I already to
hear this what were you before you
became a muslima I was nothing to be
quite honest with you my family is all
Christian yeah what kind of Christian
were they like Catholic orod Protestant
oh well my grandma my mother they're I
think
Baptist and then the rest of them are
Mormons so I don't really know if you
can call that Christian okay so you
became a Muslim three years ago
why I just I thought I was doing the
right thing
and I just I thought I felt a connection
when I started reading things about the
Gordon and the Oneness of everything
and I don't know I just thought I was
doing the right thing you just actually
confirmed what I said to the earlier
couple I said Within five years most
converts see what Islam is and they
leave give you some soless it is a fact
that 90% of converts to Islam leave
Islam within five years when they study
it they get disenchanted and they see ev
and you're already in the third year and
you're disenchanted with Islam aren't
you yeah yeah I said that see guys this
she's a miraculous confirmation what I
said and for some reason I saw you and I
thought okay maybe she is a muslima and
I've said it this is statistics most
people convert to Islam in the beginning
they think it's Sensational but as they
study and they grow they see it's not as
great as they were duped into thinking
and they lose interest and they leave
within five years so your confirmation
so where are you at
now I am in Arizona right now
and sorry not your location Sophia oh my
goodness anyway I'm saying spiritually
but anyway uh I want you to take my also
Skype name you see in the private
chat yeah
okay save it contact me later but where
are you at spiritually not your I don't
want I know I'm sorry um worry about it
very confused but leaning towards Christ
you are coming back to Christ exactly
what led you to see that Islam is not
what it's cracked up to be in Muhammad
is far from being an
example um well first of all your videos
they kept popping up on my Tik
Tok but I thought it was the shade so I
just kept ignoring them for a
while and then I was like you know what
maybe it's interesting I'll watch and
then I was fascinated and I kept
watching and
watching and then about a month ago I
had a dream wow you too
huh and um I was on uh these green
beautiful Hills and I was just crying by
myself and
for some reason like I don't know but I
don't know what happened but I just said
Lord Jesus Christ please forgive me for
everything I've done and oh Lord sorry
and it just struck me deeply and I've
just been very scared of the possible
mistake I've
made so you had a dream you were in a
field that was all green yes and then
just in the dream you started crying out
to the Lord Jesus huh yes yep yep you
you were seeing Paradise the third
heaven 2 Corinthians 12: 2 to4 so
obviously the videos the spirit was
drawing you and convicting you you saw
from the videos Islam is not what it is
Jesus is all that he claims to be and
he's infinitely
more than we can imagine he's much
greater than our thoughts so even in the
dream you were told your only hope is to
turn to Christ and ask for for
forgiveness so what is your
fear I know it's going to sound
ridiculous but just being wrong
again yep well because all I just wanted
to is just follow the lord and I thought
I was doing the right thing Y and then
for those three years I didn't feel
anything
from what I thought was God I I would
try praying and I would try everything
doing what I thought was the right thing
and I felt no connection I felt nothing
and I would I would get frustrated
because I would see everyone
else and I felt nothing and I only felt
fear like I would do everything out of
fear fear fear yep that's because the
spirit was not allowing you to have a
connection because the spirit had not
given up on
you the spirit was still working on you
convicting you to draw you so that you
felt nothing because at times Satan can
deceive you and give you a false sense
of Peace but that peace is only
temporary it too will fade and we again
we do not base it off emotion because
Jesus our lord said that those who love
me and follow me will experience
persecution we'll
experience opposition but he makes one
promise I'm G to show you
something and you've read the Quran and
I want you to compare the teachings of
Our Lord with the Quran it's day and
night Heaven and Earth let me just show
you some of the things he says
okay the peace that is true and genuine
and Lasting in spite of your external
circumstances what the world will throw
at you here John 14:27 Jesus speaking
peace I leave with you my peace I give
to you not as the world gives do I give
it to you the world will give you a
false piece of peace that temporarily
satisfies but cannot last because the
world itself cannot last it's fading so
he saying I'm not going to give you the
peace that the world offers because that
is a facade it may make you happy for
that moment but then it dissipates the
peace I give you will last in spite of
what you experience externally this is a
piece that will last and it's a peace
that you only have in me and that's why
he says do not let your heart be
troubled nor Let It Be
fearful you hear those words yes because
he's speaking to you
right John
1633 watch this these things I have
spoken to you now notice the key so that
in me and no one else and me in
fellowship with me and communion with me
and loving me and being connected to me
you may have peace in the world you have
tribulation but take courage I have
overcome the world so he's going to tell
you the world's going to give you
problems but if you are in me and
connected to me and trusting in me it
will not swallow you up because I've
conquered the world and I will preserve
you in spite of what you experience and
what you're thinking because your focus
will be on me not on your circumstances
and you're not going to depend on your
own intellect or your
strength so again these things I've
spoken to you he's telling you
beforehand doesn't lie you're going to
experience tribulation but in me you may
have peace in the world you will have
tribulation but take courage I have
overcome the
world so that's his prise but here
again watch this his promises to those
who are tired and wor and want to know
what truth is do not not let your heart
be troubled look how many
times do not let your heart be
troubled believe in God which God though
watch believe also in Me In My Father's
House the God that he wants you to
believe in is his father all of the KRON
is a father to no one you're not even
his
daughter would you ever say to Allah my
father no so that's not the god that
Jesus came to make make known because he
says this God that I want you to believe
in is my father and this is his promise
to you in my father's house are many
Dwelling Places if it were not so I
would have told you in heaven where my
father dwells there are many
mansions and I cannot lie so I'm telling
you the truth now look at his promise
for I go to prepare a place for
you and if I go and prepare a place for
you I will come again and receive you to
myself that where I am there you may be
also do you find anything like this in
your
Quran no but now watch and you know the
way where I'm going five times a day
seven actually 17 times a day you recite
F if you learned it and then you say
guide us on the straight path right yes
but now watch what he says you know
where the way I'm going Thomas said to
him Lord we do not know where you are
going how do we know the way Jesus said
to him I am the
way you've been asking to be guided in
the straight path Jesus says it's always
been
me and I've always been here and the
truth I am the truth meaning I'm reality
I cannot lie and the life everything you
wanted is in me I am your way home I am
the truth that you're Desiring to know
and I am the life your life life comes
from me and knowing me no one comes to
the father but through
me is Allah your father no then that's
not the god revealed in
Jesus that was Satan deceiving you he
goes the God that I have come to bring
you to is my father who wants to be your
father
so my question is in comparison to what
you just read from Jesus do you find
anything as close to the beauty and
teaching of Jesus and the wisdom of
Jesus in your
Quran no not at all do
you have assurance that Allah your
master not your father because he
doesn't want
children will be pleased with you when
you
die no you know what Jesus
said come to me as tired as you are as
broken as you are and I'll wipe away
your tears and I will make you a
daughter of my father and I will never
leave nor forsake you but you have to
come to
me here I stretch out my
hand Sophia I've been here I'm the one
who's been seeing your tears I'm the
one who's been weeping with you and I'm
the one whispering in your ear how much
longer will you run from
me time to come
home and home is not with Allah he has
no home for you I have prepared a place
for you remember John 14 I have prepared
a place for
you and if I prepare prepare a place for
you I will come and receive you to
myself for I am the
way and I am the
truth and I am the
life no one comes to the father without
me you cannot have God as father without
having me his son so he's asking you
will you have me will you receive me
will you trust in me will you believe in
me you have to answer
that you have to answer
it this is what I want to show you Lord
help me to show her this I am the way
the truth and life
right watch here I want to show you this
John 102730 and may the Lord recall that
let me recall that verse my sheep hear
my
voice my sheep hear my voice they know
the voice of the true Shepherd I know
them and they follow me and I give
eternal life to them they will never
perish ever if you hear my voice you can
never die you can never perish and no
one will snatch them out of my hand no
one can ever take them out of my power
my father who's given them to me is
greater than all and no one is able to
snatch them out of the father's hand I
the father
one right here see it it's right on the
screen he says my sheep will know my
voice
my question to you is when you heard
these words of Christ did you
sense that this is the one who loves you
and Ador you and has always been calling
you yeah you know why because he says
Sophia you're my sheep that's why you
recognize my
voice you're
mine you're my
sheep that's why you recognize my voice
voice so now the question
is what's your response to him because
he told Martha Martha do you believe I'm
the Resurrection Life do you believe
that if you believe me you'll never die
do you believe this her response was the
only response you can
give yes Lord I believe you're the
Christ the son of God he was to come
into the world so he's asking you
you got to answer
that do you believe what you just heard
Jesus
say yes absolutely
absolutely well here's one thing let me
read this because this is what and then
the the next step is you got to leave
Islam leave the mosque leave the Quran
start now praying to Jesus read the
Bible you're going to read Matthew Mark
Luke and John those are the gospels
about the just keep reading them to get
to know him and you got to get back to
church and that's where you contact me
on Skype we'll talk but Romans 10 9- 13
here's the next step for
you that if you confess with your mouth
meaning it has to be from your mouth
verbally like here I'm speaking with my
mouth confess with M Jesus says Lord and
believe in your heart that God raised
him from the dead you'll be saved so you
believe that Jesus died on the cross to
pay your payment and that if you receive
him you are forgiven because he died to
save you and that now he's not dead He's
Alive he rose on the third day and
appeared alive and he's in heaven will
return for with the heart a person
believes leading to righteousness
meaning if you believe in your heart God
raised them this is the faith that will
make you righteous and pleasing the
sight of God and with the mouth he
confesses leading to
Salvation for the scripture says whoever
believes upon him will not be put to
shame see it says you believe in him
he'll never embarrass you he'll never
disgrace you he'll never shame you and
he'll never remind you of your past sins
do you know
that no he didn't yes it's
forgotten your sins are forgotten he
will not remind you and throw it in your
face you remember when you did this you
remember when you said this how
no he's going to look at you he's going
to say what sins don't you know they're
gone don't you know I've removed
them don't you know I've forgiven
you the old things will not be
remembered anymore behold I make all
things new and I make you new for there
is no distinction between Jew and Greek
for the same Lord is Lord of all all
abounding in riches for all who call him
see he's Rich he has infinite spiritual
rich and he wants to Lavish you and
spoil you as daddy's little girl and his
riches whoever calls on the name of the
Lord will be saved but that's the thing
you call on me and you confess me and if
you call on me and confess me I am ready
to spoil you because you're now Daddy's
little
girl if you confess him publicly this is
what he says he'll do look
therefore anyone who confesses me before
men Matthew 10: 32:33 look you confess
me publicly and not ashamed of me I will
also confess him before my father who is
in
heaven whatever denies me before men I
will also deny him before my fathers in
heaven so here's what he's saying if you
confess me before
people I promise you the they will come
I'll take you by your hand you know what
he said he's going to do he cannot lie
see Jesus can't lie he said I'm the
truth he takes you by the hand and he
bring brings you before the father you
know what he's gonna
say with
you hand in hand he's goingon to say
father this is
Sophia she was not ashamed of me on
Earth she acknowledged me and father
behold your daughter I'm not ashamed of
her not ashamed to call her sister
receive your
daughter thank you no thank Jesus
because I'm crying because that's what
he's goingon to do for me too it's not
just you Sophia if finish the race and I
confess him the day will come where
he'll grab me by my
hand he'll take me by my
head he'll go before the
father he's going to say
Aba this is
ham
Sam he was not ashamed of
me he professed and confessed me and he
was zealous for my
glory
ABA behold your son
my
brother my
friend Sophia in your heart do you
believe this
now yes so then are you willing to
confess absolutely all right well I want
you to just say this from your heart and
contact me on Skype because then I'm
going to tell you next steps so my is
here it's in the chat right there let me
know it's you save it but
now time to come home to the only true
God who wants to be your father not just
your master and to Jesus who loves you
with an infinite love so say this from
your heart as I say you say it from your
heart because what it says if you
confess before men I will acknowledge
you I Sophia I Sophia confess with my
heart confess with my heart
Jesus is Lord Jesus is Lord he is my
Lord he is my Lord my love and my life
my love and my
life he is the Son of God he is the Son
of God and I give him my
heart and I give him my heart and I
confess and I confess God rais Jesus
from the
dead God rais Jesus from the dead Jesus
is Alive in
heaven Jesus is alive from heaven and
he'll return to the
Earth and he will return to the Earth to
judge
living sorry it's all
right and he will return to judge the
living and the dead and he is my
savior he is my savior
Lord Jesus I trust in you Lord Jesus I
trust in you and I love you and I love
you thank you for forgiving
me thank you for forgiving and please
never let me go please never let me go
and take me home to be with
Father take me home to be with father
when it's time when it's time in Your
Name Lord Jesus I pray in Your Name Lord
Jesus I pray amen amen he heard your
cries he sees your tears and what his
answer is welcome
home been
waiting father's been waiting I Jesus
have been waiting the angels have been
waiting the Saints in heaven we've been
waiting welcome home
Sophia you're home
finally and you'll never be abandoned or
forsaken in fact it's says right here it
says Heaven is rejoicing here this what
Jesus says when someone returns look
what he says he can't lie because heaven
sees you that's why he heard your prayer
I didn't hear you right you were asking
Lord if it's meant to be let him notice
right if
not you heard the words I'm about to
shut down and you're like uh oh and then
boom hey Sophia are you mus who do you
think heard your
Christ Jesus right yes and so that tells
you he's aware so now here's this
promise I tell you that in the same way
there will be more joy in heaven over
one sinner who repents than over 99
righteous persons who need no
repentance Luke 15:10 in the same way I
tell you there is joy in the presence of
angels of God over one sinner repents so
if you believe Jesus and you do he
cannot lie right now Heaven is
singing The Father smiling
Jesus is
rejoicing the angels and the Saints who
are alive Peter James
John the prophets the Blessed Mother
Mary they're all rejoicing because God
has shown them look Michael Gabriel
Peter look Sophia my daughter has come
home all because of what my son did the
Lord Jesus so contact me and I'll tell
you what the next steps are now what you
do is read Matthew Mark Luke and John
the four gospels in the New Testament
that's a life read them reread them for
a whole month just read them get to know
Jesus okay all right okay thank you
thank Jesus he loves you he's the one
who heard you not me I was about to end
it he didn't give up on you okay Lord
bless you Sister you was what amen take
care